[Music]
there we go oh man is it already Monday
it's already Monday did y'all get them
children out there you got to get them
children out there because it's
Halloween
[Music]
yeah that that's the werewolf dance it's
called that werewolf dance and you can
almost hear them when you really think
about it if you really think about that
sound you can almost hear an imagined
werewolf werewolf dancing you know
intense and together to like a lot of
people you think you know Dan werewolf
only have to dance by themselves but
werewolf's can dance together not in
groups I don't think we're they you know
one of them you know where they dance
like in a group and the one who gets in
the middle of a circle and like you know
does the you know does their best moves
and then they get out and the next
werewolf goes in I don't think it's like
that but I think I think it would be
neat actually if some of a you know a
scientist you know or somebody with
scientific information about wolves and
and werewolves you know which are I'm
guessing just [ __ ] gangster wolves
really you know or wolves you know that
know where they are as opposed to wolves
that are just kind of you know being
willy-nilly out there lost wolves but
werewolves if they could set up music
out there in the wild and then have
cameras hidden and see if these animals
would dance and of course I know that
these animals aren't going to dance to
the level that I'm think you know with
the circle and one of them gets in the
middle and does the you know the Bernie
or the you know you know the running man
or the whatever you know the you know
the twerkin or whatever I know animals
aren't going to do that but just to see
how they would behave with music with
music around because one thing that we
don't get to see a lot when you think
about it is wild animals with music we
don't when we see a lot of wild animals
just you know doing stuff and
wild animals that are put to music later
on but I feel like we don't get to see a
lot of wild animals with music so that
would be something I think interesting
to see if you're hearing the noise right
now I'm just cutting on my third camera
that's all that is okay cool thank you
guys for joining us happy Halloween you
know it's here and it's Monday and it's
October 30th and I know that my nieces
and nephews are going trick-or-treating
today down there in Baton Rouge
Louisiana and I want to let you know out
of the gate
thank you to our charter sponsor that's
great block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles on your way to the beach
okay they got the buster they got the
zingaro the deep cheese so you can meet
yourself up or you can go with that
famous salad pizza if you're leaning out
for a special quinceanera or for a
funeral show up at death's doorstep
looking sleep look and sleek your little
dark animal if you're Italian if you're
not doesn't matter it's the place gray
block pizza GRE Y block pizza calm order
online when you're in Los Angeles and
we're happy to have them and I'm happy
to have you guys happy Halloween man I
had a wild weekend I'm gonna tell you
that I went to
well first you know first I was honestly
feeling like not doing anything you know
I'll be honest with you you know what
happened was I came in Friday night you
know and Saturday at it I just woke up I
didn't really really feel like doing
much you know but a friend of mine
invited me to go to el dia de los
muertos at the Hollywood Cemetery in Los
Angeles and so next thing you know I'm
out there and I gotta say this if you're
gonna die die Mexican that's the way to
die on Halloween the this whole this
whole cemetery obviously the cemetery of
dead people in it you know and it had a
lot of you know they have some
celebrities in there and then it's got a
lot of rich you know they got a lot of
Yiddish people a lot of old old
Hollywood name
you know it's I mean it's Hollywood its
Hollywood its what Hollywood is and they
had Chris Cornell was in there he had
one of the fresher graves you know and
so he had a lot of fresh flowers by his
a lot of people taking pictures you know
the Ramones
some of the Ramones Johnny Ramone I
guess you know they had some famous
actresses and actors and and but Mexican
people and I can say Latinos but it's
Mexican I believe who take it over and
they're throwing parties I mean they're
dancing on the you know around the
graves and there's you know they're
putting all these sweet treats they got
cupcakes on the headstone and it's
really a dichotomy in your brain when
you see that because you look at a
headstone you don't think of it as uh as
a serving tray you know you think of it
as our or I've always thought of it as
let me put it on me I've always thought
of a headstone is just Oh under that
somebody dead but during el Dia de los
Muertos which is a which is the Mexican
Halloween they have like the gray it's
like part of a party it's basically
you're partying with dead people and it
sounds crazy but I realized that the way
to die is to die Mexican you know I
think living American is pretty neat I
think we got a lot you know I think I
mean obviously living American is
extremely comfortable I'm not going to
deny that you know I think that we lack
some in the UM in the sense of community
and some of those things sometimes and
and thinking about humanity first over
you know technology and those sorts of
things but whatever man those are big
picture thoughts but but if you're gonna
die die Mexican I mean I said look if I
come down with stage three cancer
brother you can guess you can bet I'm
spending that last stage that last stage
is gonna be me hick hitchhiking down the
Donna um Cancun you know up or up what
did i buy Erica you know or Nogales you
know that's what I'm gonna spend my last
stage getting because dude when you
in Mexico they come see you they put
cupcakes on your gravestone people
sitting on the side of a of a casket
sipping lemonade limonada I'm just
telling you because you know I've been
you know I've friends that are dead dude
I know some dead and I go visit them and
it's just calm you know and it's you
know you have to cry at some you know
where some of those feelings come up and
I think some of those feelings can't
come up as well in this Latin version of
being of death but I'm telling you that
dying and and dying Mexican style you
know [ __ ] I don't wrap me up in a
flour tortilla boy for you put me in the
ground embalming is for straight up you
know Gringo's on me you know I'm saying
wrap me up in a damn taquito you know
when each one of my legs wrapped in a
taquito
you can go burrito with the put with the
upper half of my body and butt down bury
me Mexican because look man I mean the
kids are out there there's candy there's
fun there's music and they have that
amazing face painting you're seeing now
where it's like this artistic skeleton
you know and it's like the kind of
jeweled kind of artistic half of the
skeleton face and they're doing all that
and that was at el dia de los muertos
but anyhow I had a great time out there
and I got a costume on so if you want to
see my costume come to the YouTube
channel and listen if you're listening
to this on iTunes on YouTube Spotify
wherever you're listening to it come and
subscribe okay can you do that for me
come and subscribe because that's how I
show what I'm doing you know that's how
I'm able to get people to come on board
and support this podcast and with that
said I want to thank my patreon
supporters that gun squad you know
they're out there and I appreciate it we
just got some new lighting they're not
up yet because I don't know how to put
them up but I'm have a guy come install
them and I'll show you on patreon the
new lights and and we'll put extended
footage on patreon
support the podcast patreon Preon comm
slash Theo von but man if you're gonna
die die Mexican or get involved in el
Dia de los Muertos find a celebration
that is close to you go check it out I
mean it blew my mind sorry I had a
little bit of coffee there I know I make
a lot of mouth sounds you know and I've
been I've talked about it before I make
a lot of you know there's a lot you can
hear me swallow and then this and that I
got a big lip you know I got that
Makemake that bottom lip I got that
sashimi
you know daddy got that uh that
sunburned snail laying a lino laying
below his upper lip so you know what I'm
saying if you ever had a like a scene of
a John and one side of it been kind of
bit by a spider that's what my I got
that bottom lip like that you know and
I'm not saying that to be vulgar but I
am saying that to be descriptive and to
be accurate because I I am trying these
days to be as accurate as I can see you
know what I'm talking about
and you know what I'm going through but
yeah man I woke up Saturday and I didn't
feel like doing anything and and one
thing that happened was that um you know
I did a comedy show Saturday night a
Friday night and enjoy Rogen was areas
in the audience and in the morning I
just how he sent me a text and he just
said hey man you were really funny last
night and uh and you know and I know
I've talked about this a little bit
before a lot of these kind you know
comedians that do that you know Coco
Diaz and uh and Rogan Kirk Fox Neal
Brennan Ian Edwards some guys that are
experienced successful and instead of
just being that and and keeping all that
to themselves you know they could just
stay in that in this we're in that world
but instead they choose to reach out
every now and then and let you know
somebody doesn't have as much time and
as much experience as them and as much
talent as them in some cases no hey man
you know I see what you're doing in I
fit and I feel like you're doing a good
job and I'll tell you this man honestly
that that's one of the things that got
me going Saturday morning
was having somebody else kind of show a
little bit of care you know summer try
to remember to do that as my week goes
on but but yeah man I went outside el
dia de los muertos had a nice time and
then and then I got into oh I'll tell
you this let me tell you a Halloween
story because you know when I grew up in
a time when you did more it you did as
much tricking as you did treating you
know you did as much tricking as you did
treating I mean they had a dude in our
neighborhood who passed away this old
man right passed away on Halloween Day
in dude I will bet you [ __ ] for rusty
shotguns that they sat that man out on
the front porch at night you know did
they tell everybody was dead no no he
were smart and your soul was and your
soul was uh you know well calibrated you
could walk up and feel if the man wasn't
living you could trust into your own
instincts as you walked up there to get
you a UH a snicker or up and you know
Ament sometime had a handful of mints
over at that house I remember and if you
got there too late all the mints it's
stuck together in the bowl cuz they were
meant that we're out of wrappers
cheapest mints you can get is you can
get a sack of peppermints you used to be
able to no wrappers on them though
that's when I grew up
candy wasn't a wrapper with something to
fancy you know you'd go to the fancy
neighborhoods if you wanted wrapped
candy
I remember you get up to that bowl you
couldn't even separate the mints from
each other you know at a certain time at
night it was whoever just whoever got to
that Bowl ran off just with a damn chunk
of mint I mean you could walk off with a
pound and a half a mint under your arm
because all the mint was stuck together
and you got all the candy and that was
it in the rest of the night people was
trying to get at you you know trying to
chip them off a little nugget of joy a
little you know their little servant of
uh of of Halloween goodness you know so
it was almost like a little bit of rugby
once who ever got to that mint house
first and got that chunk because you
could I mean only thing you do get that
Chuck away from the bowl you know
separate that big chunk of mitt cuz it
was all there was no rat you know not
everybody had rappers you know a lot of
these kids grew up in this rapper can't
you know you know places where they had
rapper you know different rappers on all
the candy some houses you went up to him
that his ass how you were feeling you
know how everything was doing how you
doing a little Fauntleroy we didn't have
all that but anyhow but I guarantee you
they left that man out there on
Halloween a real dead man on the front
porch and you know what there's nothing
wrong with that that's poor me that you
tell if I get to die on Halloween you
better [ __ ] I want you to stick both
of my hands up with all ten rigor mortis
ice cold hard fingers pointing upward
they don't want you to slowly fold down
and inward eight of those fingers and
the two fingers you leave up boy
they better be those fricking northbound
soldiers right in the middle of my hands
baby [ __ ] you that's what I'm saying
when I'm out of here and it better and
you can leave me on the front porch you
know you can even put a sign around my
neck maybe dead question mark or how
about this living question mark you know
or living uncertainty emoji you know you
can do that for me because I think
that's okay that's some of the fun about
life you know running up to somebody's
porch in the dark and not knowing if the
man in the chair is dead you know that's
how stories are started and you know
lore happens and interest and intrigue
by leaving a dead man on the porch from
maybe 18 hours to get a little bit extra
squeeze out of his life but yeah man
those were good times in Halloween and
I'll tell you another good time that I
had before I tell you about the rest of
my weekend did I went to maroon 5 had a
party last night and I went there and it
was interesting or Adam Levine and his
band Adam Levine Adam Levine from some
of y'all know him from whatever the the
chair the spinning chair you know
it's like a barber's chair but they're
helping people sing the voice you know a
lot of you guys know from that I went to
that party this weekend and I'll tell
you that about about that as well in
just a little bit we're gonna get to
that but first let me tell about this
dead bird this past weekend
now I'm not freshly shorn at the moment
but I will be at some point and you've
heard me talk of the amazing shaves that
I give myself and I get them from my
Dollar Shave Club razor especially when
I use it with their dr. Carver's shaved
butter
mmm you almost want to put it on a
waffle but legally shouldn't well I'm
here to tell you right now I never will
give up my membership in fact I'm adding
even more Dollar Shave Club products to
my daily routine Dollar Shave Club makes
products for your hair face skin shower
everything you need wash yourself treat
show shelf you deserve it they only use
the finest premium ingredients and they
deliver it to you the user just like
they do their razors no more annoying
trips to the store just open up your
door and you got that Dollar Shave Club
hit I use it for almost everything
razors body cleanser hair gel and yes
even butt wipes that's right
get between em cheeks on that Dollar
Shave Club you know I'm saying it has
you covered head to toe you can get your
first month of their best razor along
with travel sized versions of shea
butter body cleanser and yes even butt
wipes for just $5 after that replacement
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a
month it's a dollar shave club starter
set starter set get yours for this $5
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com slash
weekend
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
thanks for your support this past
weekend but first let me tell about this
dead bird so I used to live in a popular
city and I'm not gonna tell you the name
of that city in case anybody goes back
in time and tries to stalk me but I
still live in a popular city over on the
coast and
it was a beautiful city beautiful old
southern city and I lived there and one
of my friends that I lived with at one
point was a female Kiki this beautiful
girl named Kiki and she often you could
find her own rollerskates but this
particular evening she was flat-footed
and this particular evening was
Halloween and so we were both dressed up
you know or getting dressed up or gonna
get her gonna get into our costume but
we said you know what we can't be
selfish Halloween errs we need to go get
us some candy and leave it out for
somebody or many people that want to
come and get a piece of us you know
coming knock on our door because we've
been waiting for you
so we start going walking okay and on
the way to the CVS we found a dead bird
and they had a bird in this was this
bird had just died okay so i'ma say it
like that like sometimes let me say this
this bird was was freshly dead
brand-new dead let's say it like that
now if you walk up on a bird okay or if
and it's freshly dead I think you have
some responsibility to it you know like
say if you walk up on a person a person
has been dead for five days two weeks or
whatever you're just like oh yeah you
know maybe a couple snapchat things you
know maybe one filter over their face
but then you're gonna call the police
you're gonna run off you're going to
experience some fear or some disgust or
some separation you're not gonna feel an
attraction as if as compared to if
somebody has just died if somebody's
just died then you and you say yeah
they're freshly dead you know if
somebody's brand new dead then you're
gonna have feel some responsibility
towards them so what happened was me and
Kiki are walking to the CVS to get us
some candy some wrapped candies
individually wrapped and there was a
dead bird right there
brand-new dead and so we're like damn
you notice birds dead you know
but we felt some responsibility I mean
this bird had probably died a minute
before we got there maybe or 40 minutes
before but it had so recently died
that it was it was more living than it
was dead and so we felt some
responsibility towards it so we pick up
the bird and put it in a little bit of a
box you know and not a big box a small
box kind of say if you had a Cracker
Jack you know the Cracker Jack boxes
you'd a little cracker jack box right
say if you took that exact same shape of
the box but you made it about five times
you made it about five times more space
inside of it so you know it's just like
a bigger crackerjack box that a small
bird could fit down inside of it and if
you shook the Box a little you could
hear the bird move from side to side a
little bit and the box is about a foot
long I'm just trying to give you an idea
of what the box was like that we put the
bird in so anyhow we're walking over to
this CVS right and and right when we get
inside there's a man in there we're
walking around and it's kind of you know
there's kind of a vibe in the air during
Halloween where people are fun you know
people are all we're all we have a sense
of something we're all about to do
together you know like oh people are
gonna trick-or-treat or are you gonna go
to a party what's going on and so that's
the vibe that's there that's the energy
that's going on so there's a man there
now and he said you know this man was
nosey
I'm guessing and I'll tell you why he
might have been knows you because I'm
gonna tell you about what about he just
said he said what's in the box and right
there that lets me know that he's nosey
you know unless you know he has spent
his whole life wondering what's in this
particular box then I would I would say
he's more you know uh you know he's more
trying to live out his dreams but I
doubt he was doing that so I'm guessing
this man is nosey he says what's in the
box
and so I showed him this bird right dead
bird in the box there this brand-new
dead and then the dude gets pissed at me
right he's like it's not a dead bird you
know kind of offender that's not a dead
bird and I'm like do this a dead bird
did I'm not lying about I'm not gonna
lie about a dead bird I mean the bird is
dead there's nothing
you know lying about it isn't gonna get
anybody anywhere cuz nothing's gonna get
anywhere any and nobody's getting
anywhere anyway the birds did I just
happen to have it in here because it had
just died and you know if something's
just died you you know you have some
liability towards it so anyhow the dudes
like gets pissed he's like a son a debt
I'm like it's a dead bird dude touches
it Birds the head right now dudes pissed
because I told him the truth
now he gets the manager right and the
manager so the manager comes over I'll
say this about the manager he didn't
the managers like the manager didn't
speak English organically okay that's
what he said right spoke pretty much
Spanish and he goes we don't see this
bird that's what the manager said we
don't see this bird we don't see this
bird and so I tell him honestly man look
we found this bird on the side of your
building dude and then the dude says no
Rick no returns no returns man and I
don't know if this is I've never worked
at a CVS right or rite-aid or other
similar types of environments but I'll
say this dude
I guess the manager on Halloween anybody
can be a manager of CVS on Halloween I
think this dude they had just drafted
this dude you know out of like a small
division to CBS and this dude saying no
returns like I'm trying to return this
bird right and this other dude is still
complaining to him you know and the
other gentleman I'll be honest with you
bite a little tender dude he's coming a
little bit tender you know nothing wrong
with that but you know I here's what I
think honestly happened with that man
he's trying to flirt with me you know
he's trying to flirt me what's in the
box you know and then when I show him
what I got in the box you know that I
honestly have a dead bird he gets pissed
that I have a dead bird
you know like I'm lying about this like
I'm [ __ ] Dylan like I don't deal with
fake dead birds dude that's [ __ ]
that's for children if I have a [ __ ]
dead bird that bird is
dead dude you know I'm not a girl almost
po brother all right
I show if I'm showing up at the rave and
daddy that thing is LM work though you
know and then when he realized that I
had an actual dead bird and he sees that
I got my friend there Kiki's a female
you know he probably gets a little bent
out then I'm not trying to catch on to
his deal you know he tried probably
trying to be Barbara Streisand or
something you know I'm not trying to her
he trying to be a ladybug or whatever
he's trying to be you know and he
shouldn't you know he got up I could
tell I'm just telling you I'm riding
this man's vibes I mean the ill-will
towards this man or whatever his
preferences are but that was his vibe
you know he starts inching at me you
know and that's why he got the manager
over and the manager dude I thought the
manager is cute I'm like if you hitting
on anybody hit on this manager you know
this dude barely barely probably even
works at this CBS but the dude says s we
don't we don't can't everybody said no
we don't have we don't know this bird
and then he said no returns there I was
like damn man and that got me think man
no returns man
you know I got me thinking no returns
you know where did this bird go when he
was here he was gone did he return to
you know is he flying out in the ether
what's he doing now
but anyhow we left dude we put we got
back Halloween you know we're gonna go
out on the evening there in this city
this unnamed City okay I got him [ __ ]
dirty time travelers out there and I
don't put it past somebody on the dark
web to be building the time machine and
saying you know what I'm gonna go back
to where steel Vaughn lived and I'm
gonna hide out in that dudes backyard
and I'm gonna sneak up to his window at
night and watch him sit lonely at his
computer and probably jerk off I
probably feel some semblance of of on
joy but anyhow we put us we put a box
outside of the door it said just take
one we wrote on on that same box that we
had taken and the top was kind of ripped
off of this box so you got to think of a
long box almost like a shoebox if you
bisected it horizontally stand that
upright right on the side not home just
take one and then we put that like at
eye level
so you had to reach down into that box
to get a candy you know and I undid a
couple rolls of sprees in there if you
ever had that you know and then a couple
of wrapped candies butterscotches so we
gotta you know you got some individual
sprees butterscotches in there all on
top of this bird right so you had to
reach kind of down into the box and dude
you had to get you a candy brother hate
that thing so I don't know if we started
a swine flu or what we did but I will
say this when we got back home that
evening from trick-or-treating that's
only about half that candy left in that
box man
and that's God's plan and that's God's
plan you know and that's truly beautiful
that's Halloween
that's Halloween doing fun [ __ ] you know
I'm when we filled this dude we had a
dude in our town mr. Mike and he had a
he'd lost a limb you know and he said it
was in battle but I don't think it was
in battle dude honestly I think he's
probably [ __ ] around somewhere by a
truck or by some machinery
well we filled his leg up with custard 1
year to vanilla custard right so we're
waiting all night for him to get back by
his legs because this dude was I want to
say he was homeless but he was outdoors
all the time to the point where you 90%
of the time you wondered if he had an
indoors and and he uh dude we saw him
finally catch that limb bro he's putting
it back on dude going to seize it as
full of this custard it took that [ __ ]
straight to the dome dude straight to
the dome and that's Halloween and that
was a bizarre picture I remember that
kind of almost enhanced my imagination
was watching a man and I think he was on
liquor at the time he looked like he was
on liquor and he was always on liquor so
I wouldn't assume if I saw him at some
point that he wouldn't have been on
liquor and this was you know some point
so I saw this man drinking custard out
of his own leg and until you've even
seen it it just takes your brain to
another place because you don't think
that that's something realistic you know
you don't think that that something's
gonna happen that somebody's gonna take
a sip of something a sip of a sweet
sauce out of their own appendage you
don't think that and at that point
that's when your brain can get a little
bit
Tim Burton in it you know when you when
your brain sees things in a way that
they aren't normally you know but those
are two good Halloween stories that I
had or whatever they are that was some
of my Halloweeny but I'm a newsie that's
what I'm dressed up as in a newsie is a
character from a musical Christian Bale
was in it and I'll put the link to the
bye in the in the YouTube comments and
section you know and all of that you can
check it out but I'm a newsie for
Halloween this is what I've been for a
few years because I don't prepare enough
you know and I haven't really had a
lover to go out with on the Halloween
much so you know my doing with any of
those dual costumes you know I did I did
geez I did I did honest I did dress up
like Jesus one year with the wooden
cross and everything in Tucson Arizona I
think I was going through a weird period
took that to a party and my girl at the
time was dressed like the devil
dressed like Satan so and she was a bit
of a of a see-you-next-tuesday
if you will take that acronym but she
was also she was cool she was fun but
but anyway man that was uh that was a
wild one that I had what else I dressed
up like a damn I think of pdf-file one
time or just you know I get the
moustache made out of my own body hair
like they used to do in prison and I
would do the long sleeve shirt with the
leather elbow patches packing the
crayons in the pocket dark sunglasses
and a moustache you know that word
curtain popped that word curtain right
above the lip you know and just stand
there all night don't say anything
some of us pedophile or just like
something that makes you think of
darkness you know because that's one
thing about Halloween you know so now I
want to see the dark arts you don't want
to see the dark arts put on a fashion
show that's Halloween you know I want to
see young Danny do my boys jump off the
side of that [ __ ] tailgate right in
the sheer darkness thinking he's landing
in somebody's yard going to
trick-or-treating the rich people's
neighborhood and come neck to face to
neck with a UH with a fire hydrant
that's in somebody's yard you know
that's what I want to experience I want
to play kick-the-can with some dude fat
Jeremy and nobody ever found him ever
and this has been probably almost 26
years anyhow man that's what's going on
dude that was some of my Halloween Oh
then I went to the maroon 5 we're gonna
get into a few calls then I went to the
maroon 5 I also want to tell you guys if
you didn't listen we had to Brock follow
up last week we had Brock called in from
Central Missouri young fella 20 years
old called in dealing with some you know
some confidence issues and you know
gravitationally advanced you know short
small whatever we all got something dude
and and we had a bunch of good responses
calls him for him that came in and so we
put that up a special follow-up episode
and that's on iTunes and on YouTube you
can check it out that's this past follow
up with Brock but let me tell you about
this so you know had the fun day did
that got home and then I'm going to the
the maroon 5 party right I get there
well first I wanted messing people for
dinner man this would it's like all
right my buddy sets up this dinner like
he's got like you know some girls that
he knows from another country or in town
in LA right you know some fancy dudes or
cool cool cool dudes you know they're
they're you know I don't know any of
them and I get to the restaurant late
I'm there nine minutes I got like all
the leftover foods like at one end of
the table right so I eat real quick
introduce myself to some people and then
I get I got to pay part of the bill none
of the girls pay offer to pay right so
each dude throwing in 200 buns right on
this food and I'm like [ __ ] this right
that's what 60% of me said but 40% of me
said you know I told my buddy Mike I
would be here he warned me in advance
that you know sometime we split that we
have the man take care of the bill and
I'm like well you know I don't do this
Hollywood experience type of night that
much because it's not my vibe I'm just
gonna be a part of it and see what
that's you know just be a part of it you
know sometimes being just getting [ __ ]
on the money that's part of something
that's part of whatever it is you know
yes the next thing you know you know I
put chipped in on this [ __ ] meal [ __ ]
so I'm angry we get outside you know my
buddy Mike he's got a nice car everybody
gets in his car then like leftover
people are getting in my car then they
all get out of my car you know and want
to take an uber so that left me feeling
kind of weird I thought it was maybe
they didn't like my coat you know I
start feeling inferior ideas you know
popping in my head I'm not cool you know
people don't like me my car isn't you
know neat enough or fancy enough you
know and I got a neat car you know I
mean as far as you know you know I treat
myself to a decent car nothing
outrageous but you know it's fun car
it's cool it's neat but uh but but
anyhow so now driving out to the party
by myself
oh but and then I find out later that
everybody took an uber they were gonna
get drugs right I don't do drugs
you know what I'm sayin bruh so now I've
done drugs and I'll drop stories I'll
drop stories to do it I will take a
medium-range story of mine and throw it
up against the best story you haven't
even had yet dude I'll mail you a eight
ball for your 30th birthday you know and
flying a couple of Guatemalans dog and
semi friend veiled Rijn who has DS and
parties dude have you ever known anybody
with their with des at parties but this
dude he's got that syndrome bro and he
gets down bro but um and I'll still
match that story any mold stories you
know because I still want to be you know
competitive in the you know in the fun
game but anyhow I find out that they all
went to get drugs and I'm gonna do drugs
so at least that made me feel a little
bit better but I'm I'm already kind of
nerd you know not nervous but just I
don't do these kind of parties that much
you know but I get there right when I
get there Jeff Ross is there you know
him from the roastmaster right and I'm
not name-dropping but I am Telling You
he was there and he's going in this like
private entrance there's a regular
entrance as a back entrance right for
this maroon 5 Halloween party you know
and you don't feel like moon 5 that's
fine they just throw a party every year
that's like a hip party
and so I'm excited to be going you know
so Jeff's like hey bro just come in with
me you know I'm like one waiting for my
friends are not here yet because none of
them wanted to ride with me
so he's like I didn't tell him that part
but he said come inside you know coming
with me so next thing you know I go in
with Jeff and his buddy kai and
literally right we walk in well it does
like this back I mean it's this place
you know like all sportsmen's lodge and
it's all like I mean there's like a pond
and there's like it does like little
bridges going over it and there's like
little enclaves here and there and
there's you know there's a huge rumor
there's gonna be a performance and
there's another room with as a DJ and
another there's like little bars placed
all over there's an outdoor bar an
indoor bar and it's probably I mean the
whole thing is probably as big as half
of a football field you know and then
all these little stations are all over
the place or maybe a third of a football
field let's say that anyhow man having a
good time actually maybe half sorry but
anyhow you know we walk in and then
there's Adam Levine and he'd have a wig
you have a long wig and he have skeleton
facepaint skeleton face paint and a long
wig and he and he just like hey Jeff
what's going on he starts talking to
Jeff Ross Jeff introduces me and then he
starts saying that we're gonna be ac/dc
tonight and we're gonna play his band is
gonna play like six ac/dc songs and I
will put a little bit of that footage
into the YouTube so you can just see
what it was like I'll put that at the at
the top of the YouTube so you can see
what that's like but but anyhow and next
thing you know like it was kind of neat
just to hear and I'll say this the guy
had a really nice vibe super friendly
I've always heard that he's a friendly
guy Adam Levine but but anyway super
nice dress is like kind of like a trance
not like a cross-dressing I guess is
more the term cross-dressing skeleton
and he had on like a choker and he's got
on this wig but he starts saying that
they're gonna play you know 6ac
ac/dc songs so suddenly I feel a little
bit more comfortable
because now I've like met the guy whose
party it is you know I'm here with Jeff
Ross who kind of Jeff Ross is like this
kind of roaming dinosaur when he's
anywhere he's just he always has this
like confidence about him which at a
party is really nice because he's been
in LA forever he knows everyone and uh
and he just feels comfortable kind of
wherever he is is his home turf you know
so anyhow we rolled around this party
and there's some great costumes man I
mean there's everything from like the
scariest stuff - you know pregnant
people
oh one guy one guy had a a like a tablet
on his front and a tablet on his back
and he had a shirt and the tablets were
like you know there were house like
rectangles cutout on the shirt and there
was a tablet a rectangle cut out in the
front rectangle cut out in the back and
the tablet a tablets on each side you
know so if the screens facing out out
his back and out on the front and
somehow he had this camera situation is
set up where you could see through him
so if you were standing behind him the
screen showed what was through him on
the other side and if you were standing
in front of him that screen showed what
was behind him so so bizarre man like
the dude you could literally be watching
the performance if you stood behind him
you could be watching the performance
through a human so I had never done
anything like that man you know I've
never looked through anybody you know
I've stared maybe into an orifice or two
but I've never really you know looked
through someone but but anyway so next
thing you know walking around this party
had a good time the band plays there was
some really bizarre like hallways and
stuff you could walk down you know
people are on Molly people are on
ecstasy people are on you know you can
see some cocaine here and there you know
everybody has wigs on so as long as
anybody's got semi-decent cheekbones
everybody looks fine as [ __ ] you know
trying to think of some great costumes
that I saw man or so many there's a
bunch of Harvey Weinstein's oh they kind
of had this black guy who was dressed as
a bull chained to the wall and people
were taking pictures with him it was
almost like
exhibit little slavish to me honestly
and a lot of people were saying that and
if you had taken this I thought about
this if somebody done this at a party in
South Carolina North Carolina Alabama it
would not have gone over well right but
in California it's for some reason
that's not inappropriate right to have a
black man chained up dressed as a bull
and in really in my mind I didn't think
my first thought isn't oh this dude is
this you know my first you know this is
like some slavery enactment my first
thought is oh they just got a guy to be
a bull the guy happens to be black you
know he doesn't have a shirt on he's
shackled on each arm to the wall and he
just has pants on right the little
bizarre but that's my first thought but
then in the scope of the world or the
universe and the media especially in
America I'm thinking that if someone did
this in the south or in the middle of
America that's somebody in one of you
know some media person would say oh look
how [ __ ] up these people are for doing
this this is so wrong but as long as
it's in in a place like Los Angeles or
New York or a big city then it's okay
you know I just I don't like those I
just don't like how I I don't know that
kind of stuff I don't like when things
are unfair and I think that so that's
what online took it my mind took it like
oh well if somebody did this you know
where I'm from and they would be looked
at as a racist even though they were
just trying to achieve the same goal as
someone is here which is just to have a
neat exhibit and it gives a man some
work who is obviously an artist or an
entertainer or a model I mean the guy
was Jack you know he had like you know a
very strong shoulders and physique so
anyway I don't know that [ __ ] was super
bizarre if I can find a picture of that
I'll put that at the front of the
YouTube as well just so you can check it
out but that was it man I walked around
I saw some gal that I've hooked up with
a while back
she-she [ __ ] I don't know
she's have a drug problem I think she
still does made me glad that I wasn't
with her just because I don't want to
have be having that problem you know I
talked to some new friends and when I
was leaving I'm always leaving out by
myself and there's Adam Levine in the
same place as I'm walking out in this
like back little area and and I'm not
trying to name-drop here but I'm just
telling you this story you know this is
a to me this is kind of a Hollywood
story so he goes hey would you think of
the show and I thought it was awesome
like Sammy Hagar got up there I said
dude I didn't know that I liked ac/dc as
much as I did because the show was
[ __ ] awesome like I mean I love ac/dc
apparently I didn't know that I mean he
took me back to my childhood of the song
and me it was great and um and he goes
man I didn't know that either he's like
I've been listening to him for the past
month just because I you know I've just
wanted to get in tune with the song so I
could sing him but he's like I didn't
know that either he's like where's Jeff
Ross I said I think they're about to
leave and then I grab Jeff and they and
they chatted for a little while there
was like kind of a little bit of a group
conversation I think some people seemed
to uh you know hi on whatever whatever
they were doing having a good time and
that was it man and then I drove home
and that was my Halloween you know that
was my that was my Halloween so just
wanted to share that with you man you
guys we had some calls come in I'm sorry
that I took so long I've taken so much
of this episode for myself but I'm
dressed like a newsie which is when a
Christian Bale's early films if you want
to go check that out I believe it's on
Netflix now it's a musical and it's
about when they didn't have papers
anymore people couldn't sell papers
anymore and there was a law or an issue
with it but let me let me get to some
calls right now I got to get out of here
I'm actually doing Joey cocoa Diaz his
podcast as well tonight but let's get
some calls here here we go this one is
from across the pond where they might
celebrate Oh Halloween yo tio what's up
man calling from Ireland Dublin
Christian hear ye Thank you very
much for calling i'm if your name is
christian or if you were christian but
either one you're welcome here brother
thank you for calling homeward just
calling just to send my love right out
to you that last episode [ __ ] mom you
know just spilling your heart out
talking about love talking about you
know your difficulty accepting at a
times and I don't know man I just
appreciate I appreciate your podcast and
really when you lay it out like darling
when you lay it out so bare helps me you
know it reminds me that I'm not the only
one it feels certain ways about certain
things so yeah hello I appreciate it man
I mean to cut you off there but I
appreciate it
you know I not do appreciate that
sentiment you know yeah my brother told
me whenever I started this podcast I had
him listen to an episode and and my
brothers you know my brother's really
you know he's the love of my life you
know to be honest with you you know I'm
gonna always would have said that as a
as a child but uh because we didn't know
each other but as I've gotten older you
know he has been you know he's been like
uh I mean a father to me at some times
you know a role model a leader if Damus
just got me choked up he's been
everything to me man you know and and he
listened to an episode when I first
started this podcast and he said man you
know he said it's weird you just you
know you're just putting your thoughts
and your feet you putting your feelings
out there and you're sharing a lot about
yourself and I say yeah you know and he
goes just be careful you know he said
just be careful and if people call in
and they share about themselves just be
grateful you know and uh and so that's
just what I've tried to do man you know
I try to be a little bit careful because
I don't want to be you know have nothing
for myself that I don't share but at the
same time
I'm sick of being in a [ __ ] world
where you know people just try feel like
we're always just getting tricked with
[ __ ] and things aren't real like why
we have to have like you know why there
have to be so many layers of unreality
for us to just share like whatever's
kind of the truest thing to us sometimes
and anyhow I know I'm going off on a
tangent uh but yeah man I look I
appreciate that call and I get some
other ones like this and I mean honestly
you know I get a get a decent amount of
calls like this and and I like to this
one from one because I like the accent
you know and you know you say you know
that accent is just charming you know
and it made me feel good to know that
somebody far away in Ireland has and I'm
homeless dressed it off a dress like
kind of like an Irish lesbian right now
but uh in this news the outfit but that
somebody far away has some of you know
that we can have similar feelings
because it just inspired me and made me
think even more that you know that we're
just how similar we all are you know but
yeah I try to put myself out there man
you know sometimes this holds this show
is like make it just give me an
opportunity to think and to feel and and
I just I don't know I'm just a mom I
mean my emotions are so close to what
I'm doing all the time for some reason
and a lot of my life I haven't liked
that about myself because it's hard for
me to hide the way I feel sometimes like
if I'm talking to somebody it's hard for
me to you know if I'm nervous or if I'm
excited or if I'm you know lying you
know all those things very hard for me
to hide them because whatever I'm it's
right there with me all the time or if
I'm you know feeling admiration or
feeling loved it's always hard for me to
it's hard for me to hide some of those
things sort of yeah I don't know I don't
know I'm talking about right now man but
I appreciate your call dude you know and
you guys do that for me you know you
guys call in and give out the [ __ ] you
know and give out the feelings and you
know I just wanna [ __ ] I'm just I
hate I just hated living in a world for
so long where
people aren't doing that you know I just
got tired of hearing about some [ __ ] I
want to hear what make what's making you
feel something you know that's what I
was wanted to hear so but look man
you're welcome
that's all I mean to say dude [ __ ]
does the most long-winded you're welcome
let's get let's move to another call me
you're welcome and uh and I love having
you as a listener man and I appreciate
you being you know willing enough to
share how you felt about that you know
to call up another dude and leave a
voicemail you know and just say look man
I appreciate what's going on I
appreciate you for that let's hear
another one here we go I would love to
hear you talk more or talk sometime
about interacting with wild animals I
think around the time when we grew up we
did a lot more with them kids are doing
nowadays and some funny [ __ ] always
happened I'm a wildlife biologist and so
I'm out in the wilderness all the time
mostly in Alaska and Central America and
I kicked a caribou in the face one time
when I got charged I had to choke out of
this one in a survival situation and
[ __ ] happens up here up there long
enough so I bet you got some funny
stories about possums and raccoons and
god only knows what from growing up damn
bro first of all I had to choke out a
swan in a hostage situation I think you
said maybe the quote of a lifetime if
you hear this
and I'll go back and look for your
number on the Google voicemail and also
you can hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three if you
have a thought or call or an idea
anything anything you want to contribute
to the podcast hit it up but dude yeah I
mean I remember fine and they had some
man in our in our town I guess had been
trying to get a I don't fit was a I
guess a peacock or something to run
cocaine form they found peacocks had
like a cocaine kind of taped around her
neck you know and they found three of
them and so this had been somebody was
trying to train Cox or you know peacocks
and Cox is short for that to uh to run
dope you know and and I guess it's not a
bad idea
you see a peacock the last thing you're
thinking this animal have cocaine on it
you know you're looking at the show
you're looking at the you know the big
flare the flared tail comes out you're
looking at that you're not thinking this
animal run running dope and so that's
really it's a smart idea because they're
putting on that show and meanwhile
they're selling dope on the side and you
know it's almost like when a hooker
sells drugs you know you so hypnotized
by that Posse that you ain't a lot of
time thinking that they might be drug
mule and you know the amount of balloons
full of our heroine and in her buttocks
because you're so keyed in on that
vision you ain't even thinking that just
inches away that boots Hawks may be
holding you know kilos of dope and so
that's a beautiful you know that's a
beautiful that's beautiful man it's
what's happening out there
but yeah somebody was trying to do that
I remember do that a lady trained
butterflies to be around her you know
and I'm gonna she was hiding you know
seed in her hair or doing you know
hiding you know putting different types
of sugar drip or something in her hair
or honey behind her ears or whatever but
she was training these butterflies to be
around her and she would get stung by
the bees and wasps and stuff and you
know other non be non butterflies
we'll call them but she she did a decent
job of having those uh those butterflies
around but yeah I remember doing a lot
more than were getting attacked my
animals you know getting attacked my
animals a lot dude watching dogs making
love a lot in the neighborhood we they
had a dachshund that I swear to God took
somebody's virginity in our neighborhood
on accident you know you saw some things
you know had a bad wire in our
neighborhood on one of the powerlines
and birds were always getting
electrocuted up there you know dead
birds and you would and most of the time
when I found them they would be dead
long enough where I knew I don't have
any semblance of responsibility towards
them anymore and that's one thing you
noticed with animals but look man I
would love it and I'm gonna reach out to
you I want to hear more about these
animals and I and we might have animal
questions for you you know so I'd love
to hit you up with some animal questions
and and see what we can get out of you
bro and get some
information because it seemed like you
have you are a man that has information
and I appreciate you calling but yeah
there was a better time when people and
animals interacted more and I wasn't a
Tarzan you know I'm saying I didn't grow
up in the jungle I just grew up in
Covington Louisiana I grew up in a small
town you know I grew up in population
probably maybe 3,000 3,800 3,900 you
know good people doing their best mixed
vibe out there you know I grew up out
here in America
alright let's hear a little bit more
onward hey Co my name is Brock Ames I'm
from right outside Atlanta Dallas
Georgia and you just said something on
this lady's podcast that kind of really
resonated with me talking about the
Emmys and what not how I just you know
nothing feels real anymore
it really doesn't it's like it's like
people almost try to capitalize on how
authentic they are but I don't know it's
troubling it's troubling if you're
really into art in any format but that's
why I really think people like you and
Joe Rogan and Donald Glover are just you
know just gems gems in the world hey man
I appreciate that dude and this isn't a
UH
I didn't mean I'm not trying to make
this podcast uh you know only play calls
that say nice things about Theo episode
but I did I like this call and this
calls awhile back is from the Emmys and
some calls look man you know I get a lot
of voice messages and we'll keep them in
a rotation until at a time when it fits
or when a time when I can use it but
yeah I agree man you know and it's a
struggle to find out what's real and
it's one of the things that keeps me in
bed it's one of the things that defeats
me a lot of times you know that nothing
is real you know that this is all world
as victims of commercialism and that
we're not even are we even in charge of
Rome brains a lot of times because you
know there's so much data collected by
the choices we've made especially with
the internet so in I mean the Internet
is just a place where everything we do
is so monitored accurately monitored
mathematically monitored that equation
can be made to figure out who we are and
what we're gonna do next it's baffling
but yeah that nothing is real anymore
you know and I think I feel like that
I'm kind of in a search for that right
now myself and I think a lot of people
in the world are you know especially in
American I you know or a lot of people
in the America that I see and it could
just be my perspective but I think I can
but you know what I
I feel it dude I feel in my bones and in
my heart that a lot of people are
looking for just what they want [ __ ]
that's real I don't want this fake [ __ ]
you know I don't want this fake [ __ ] I
don't want some fat you know celebrity
who's lying to me just to you know fill
some image you know or you know you have
a lot of like past years you've got a
lot of female celebrities hop on the
feminism bandwagon just to make money
don't think we didn't see that we're not
ignorant you know yeah I mean it's just
I don't like seeing some things that
just aren't genuine you know or at least
trying to be you know it just it's tough
man we one of you want we want to try
and find things that are real we want to
have real moments with people and uh and
yeah I I appreciate that and that's why
I appreciate some of you guys as calls
man you know and I appreciate some of
these moments too because yeah we're out
here just looking for something real man
that's what I'm doing I know this would
tell a lot of you guys are doing [ __ ]
dude I have to go do I gotta go do Joey
cocoa Diaz his podcast right now
promised might be there I'm already
gonna be late but I'm gonna come back
and finish this up a little bit later
tonight so I'll just have to put this
[ __ ] costume back onto it but man I'm
enjoying this time with you guys nothing
is real man or what is real what are we
looking for
I don't remember let's get into that
next episode maybe we'll do that how
about that let's get into that next
episode there's a couple other calls
that are really good that I want to get
to but we're gonna do it next week
there's already been a long episode but
what's real anymore you know what is
real how do you find out what's real
what do you search for what do you do
what do you recommend I love the fact
that people
in a podcast I love the fact that a
gentleman just recommended to me Donald
Glover you know cuz I didn't know that I
want to check him out you know I love
the fact that um that you hear guys on
these podcasts who were sharing real
[ __ ] you know I love the fact that we're
creating a culture here on this past
weekend where you know this follow-up
episode with Brock that we that we put
up last week man it was one of it was it
was a really neat I thought it was fun
for me do not on set you know really I
thought was cool dude how many people
called him and with different accents
and different thoughts and [ __ ] like
you know other people that are shorter
experiencing [ __ ] you know damn we just
got so like everybody feels alone but
we're not alone man we're just so
separate now we're so separate you know
we're in our own cars were we're in our
own homes you know we're not in groups
we're not seeing what's going on we're
not seeing when our knit when our friend
is struggling you know even in the old
days you could tell in a heartbeat your
buddy shoulders were a little bit sunken
you you knew in a heartbeat to put your
hand on his back you know or to you know
pay for his gum at the dime store or
whatever you know you knew in a
heartbeat to let him ride your bike if
you got the new bike you know I mean you
knew things you know you saw somebody
that you know a kid shooting hoops by
himself in the neighborhood you knew to
pull over you know to bike on over there
just say what's up walk through his
ditch to come up the other side of his
ditch what's go home an you know you
could tell just by somebody's behavior
what's going on but we don't see
people's behaviors that much anymore you
know we're just getting to separate you
know and that's one of the things that's
like and I don't know how to heal that
and it's not my responsibility to heal
that either I you know I'm not feeling
this insane responsibility but I guess I
just you know what do I do for myself to
heal it um you know I try to keep in
touch with my loved ones you know
I try to when somebody says something
nice to me like the dude from Ireland
said I try to let that you know resonate
in me for a second instead of just you
know um I try to listen a little bit
with my heart so let that [ __ ] hit me
down in that [ __ ] ticker and that
blood ticker you know you know I talked
to my mother he went I don't want to
sometimes you know I don't know but I'm
learning what do you do man what do you
do what do you do to keep [ __ ] real in
your life you know that's what was so
great about Halloween back in the day
was you it was an escape that was an
escape now it's Halloween every moment
of our lives you know with social media
but that was an escape man but yeah
let's do that for next week man hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three happy Halloween to
you guys you know if you got some kids
out there with some beautiful you know
you got some beautiful children get some
photos of them you know you know get out
there and trick-or-treat and hold your
wife's hand while you're walking down
the street you know or if you got an
ex-wife and y'all made those children
together and you taking them
trick-or-treating take a cute picture
you know cinema I mean these these are
things you're gonna do anyway but if you
get that feeling in your heart that man
this is something I should do right now
that's your instincts you know and if
you got a good heart and your instincts
are gonna be good you know you have to
start to you know and I say that because
I sometimes I doubt my own instincts
even though I know that my heart is
trying to be in the right place you know
just some self-doubt and [ __ ] I don't
know man I'm a little bit all over the
place today but it's Halloween bro you
know and I'm just I'm just a dead bird
dude I'm just a dead bird in a box
you know just trying to get uh trying to
get returned at a CVS ma'am
but I love you guys appreciate you guys
for being here happy Halloween hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three if you have an a
mail issue if you're dealing with a mail
issue and you live in the California
area hit me up on the hotline let me
know what's going on it could be a
relationship issue it could be a
self-worth issue it could be
any man issue any issue that you're
dealing with as a man it could be
anything from a wrecked-tile dysfunction
to you know you're feeling short you
know we just maybe we're doing a new
pilot for Comedy Central and we may be
using may be using some people who have
actual real problems you know so we'll
see what's up man
y'all be good take care brush your hair
be good to yourselves I bet you deserve
it I liked it in here we go
[Music]
werewolf boy he wild and he Wow
it's crazy right there that's a good
stuff I'll be good man
[Music]